herzlich willkommen zum heutigen video
leute ich bin jedoch zusammen mit jana
und mit einem ehrengrab wird zum ersten
mal erstellt wird dazu gehört dazu mike
es zum allerersten kanal dabei den nicht
kennen kann auf jeden fall einen großen
fehler in seinem leben gemacht und micky
ist der meinung dass ich ein weiterer
der nicht essen kann und das war als ich
mir letztens firmenvideo verschiedene
superscharfe sachen bestellt
da hatte ich mir das muss ich eigentlich
bin michael testen und als jahren
dachten sie diese tatsächlich einfach
auch mit ja oder ja hier sind hier
werden die deppen up challenge 2.0 und
ich guck mal kurz auf die rückseite es
ist wahnsinn
die erste von diesen müssen es mit
carolina also mit der schärfsten chili
der welt und die letzte hat 13 millionen
zum vergleich ich bin mir nicht sicher
auch wieder ankommen werden wir müssen
dran bleiben und zusehen ob der ob jetzt
dahin schaffen aber 15 millionen hat die
schärfste chili der welt und 13
millionen hat diese letzten monaten ja
genau tabasco wasserpreis 5000 oder
sonst also wir haben wirklich kranke
sachen hier
ich würde sagen wir fangen wir an mit
schafen rahmen wird also koreanischen
die koreanischen rasenden hier habe ich
schon vorbereitet und gehen er und
einfach mal alle eine gabe davon gucken
werden uns am besten klarkommt ich habe
das schon gemacht aber sie schmecken ja
auch möglich ein bisschen schüsse auf da
brauchen wir haben sahne milch und brot
gegen die schärfe damit wir klarkommen
ihr müsst wissen sollte ich war bis vor
einem jahr oder zwei jahren oder so er
lernte er sich jetzt gar nicht vertragen
ist immer alles angesprochen beim ganzen
tag mir deshalb sicher zeit meiner
katholischen die gar nicht neu für mich
jedoch weise unsere größen abstimmen
möchten so aufrecht ich hier bin ich so
oft findet okay okay
daher sagt man so zwar schmecken ojo
worauf ich mich eingelassen
das ist mit abstand das ihs etwas hört
wir haben das hier freunde
das hier ist eine schokoladentafel und
das ist die schärfste schokolade der
welt in der regel doch nicht scharf aber
nichtsdestotrotz also jetzt gern nochmal
vergabe davon jetzt so nach 100 minuten
nachdem ich die jahre gegeben habt schon
gar nichts mehr also da komme ich gut
klar
so schmeckt die uns richtig so green die
schnecken richtig lecker von der
flammenwerfer süßigkeiten vertrieb kommt
die wahrscheinlich schärfe süßigkeit auf
der welt glaubst du trotz sich dieses
für diesen lollipop zu essen 9 millionen
scoville
das ist schon krass in einen ganzen
leute wir haben nämlich abstufung und
die anderen sachen wahnsinnig scharf
fünf immer knapper werdende er konnte
nicht mehr atmen immer stärker werdende
erdnüsse mit den schärfsten chilis der
welt ich glaube irgendwann schmerzen
gutes schmerzen auch die jetzt hier das
ist sogar alles erklärt also als erstes
haben wir gerne startet in carolina und
schaukelte das kenne ich nicht kenne ich
habe echt angst das brett zu werden es
ist so schade das hat dieses rennen
richtig und das ist nicht so wie bei das
ist nicht so wie bei richtigen chaseco
des bundes brennen anders ist auch gerne
einfach mal probieren
okay wir müssen zusammen bilden
schmecken tun die schon mal nicht dass
noch was kommt da noch was es wird
schlimmer glaubt ja also aktuell geht's
noch das ist schon gegessen der die
hälfte ist es schärfer als die rahmen
auf jeden fall hilfreich war der erste
nach hause ich finde ich dass mein
körper rasch ich muss ich hab jetzt
schlechte laune nicht mehr raus aber in
der stufe 2 direkt in stufe super rück
aus irgendeinem grund haben sie auch für
eine gute idee gehalten so weit kommen
wird das schärfen luke die schärfsten
sachen der welt zu holen war nicht so
schlau
einfach nummer drei jetzt probieren wie
so oft zweiter
ich mache jetzt mal eine gute idee wir
nehmen einfach auf jedem einfaches und
dann müssen wir mal so ihm ist verrückt
ich erste hälfte aber es ist schon
schmecken wieso honig mäßiger dabei die
sozis machen aber man brauche die leute
noch mal richtig drauf des frage ist
extreme ist fairtrade stadt zug aufs
kind noch richtig schmeckt am besten
okay das ist für meine schärfen des pop
bremst rangers hatte ich empfehle nicht
zuhause zu probieren
ich glaube ich kann mir schon vorstellen
dass sie gleich machen schmerzen hast
freunde bitte wenn ihr das video seht
ihr sie jetzt wahrscheinlich wenn mein
tropf klassenleiterin hört einfach beide
töten uns für euch nummer vier ist der
schmerz selbst ein und zweimal carolina
republik oft kurz pause zieht durch mach
ja alles auf einmal
das ist schon rein ist sofort schafft
diese diese extrakte des schmecken erst
später
denkst du überhaupt die menschliche zone
keinen unterschied ja ich möchte
wirklich kein unterschied das war so
nicht es gab keine abstufung irgendwie
13 millionen sich zeit die letzte
gehörst du zu ihm wird deshalb die todes
nuss zweimal carolina ritterhuder
scorpion 13 millionen kubik capsaicin
crystals ok wissen bereit eine pause
kann zieht mich einfach freude werde ich
das geschafft habe dann hast du alles
geschafft dann hast du das bag von ihm
bekam ich nenne ich nun da diese meiler
kenneth chenault am besten anwalt
das ist meine stufe 5 wir sind uns nicht
sicher ob das studio hofft dass bald
oder weitergehen doch auf die stufe 4
anja okay das ist jetzt unser leben oder
scheiße okay okay das ist okay 30 allen
probiert habe dieses gefühl so fangen
man was ist unser und mein magen kommen
kannst du mal 13 millionen bewertet
ich muss lange an das video braucht man
schon so richtig tritt wieder in hamburg
installative von pippa denken wo er so
über der toilette auch koch weiter also
über der toilette hängt und so aus allen
löchern so rocks wunsch da aber fühlt
sich aber populistisch handelsrecht bei
der umweltprämie werde ich denke ich
meine zunge kommen würdest du deine oma
du kannst dich reden und dich niemand
ist es nicht manchmal als junge ich kann
doch nicht gebraucht
die mutter erst mal den punkt erreichen
und zu lange zeit haben ich konzentriere
mich gerade darauf zu sterben
der boden warum ist so ich bin michael
ist so lässt wenn ich ruhig bin heißt es
scharfe also meine empfehlung ist
möglich wäre neuer leben lang gegessen
habe es brände haben aber das projekt
roberta vinci dies ist wenn ihr beide
mussten dafür so auch 0 sind und nun und
dann irgendwie welle bürgerschaft nichts
zu essen oder zu trinken also leute das
wird so schlimm wie ich glaube dass die
rede ist eine brands mehr
man darf auch nicht besser
ich hatte echt nicht gedacht dass es so
schwer wie geht es euch auch nicht gut
finde das video bisher gefordert lasst
doch gern das so wir machen nicht immer
kommen gemacht
schokolade platz hier ist die schärfste
cola der welt sieht so niedliche
auszuprobieren
wo kommt ihr auf jeden fall sagt schaffe
schaffe nimmt das stück von den
schärfsten schokolade der welt und mikey
also es ist nicht so schlimm - dann
kommen können für uns steht die bank
schneller aber es bringt nichts zu
schweben die dafür genannt werden
ja oh ja ich bin ruhig das heißt wir
wissen es ist scharf ist
heute müssen wir diese anstalt wird
könnte kotzen vielleicht ist in den heiß
du musst die packung hofft die spitze
mit und über schafe nicht so schlimm wie
sogenannte back also leute ich kann
wirklich ein video das mich an meine
grenzen gebracht hat das war auch
höchste erfahrung also ich kann jetzt
auf jeden fall eben gut erzählen
das ist richtig scharfe sachen gegessen
so durch youtube kanal kommen zeitung
sprung gemacht und ich habe 13 millionen
scoville gegessen das sind alles gute
und storage jemand erzählen können aber
das ding ist wenn das reicht so gut
gefallen hat dann koche ich meine
richtig scharf ins gericht was das ist
dann aber lecker und unscharf und ich
gucke mal wie viel von nämlich von den
nudeln
es ist halt mit richtigen stelle
geschnitten so ein gerät ein richtiges
gericht ja also ich denke auf jeden fall
seine leidensgenossen afp lange dass sie
mich nicht alleine gelassen mit dem zeug
hier wir passen jetzt auch weiterhin auf
wir sind hier auf jeden fall raus dann
bleibt uns mal wieder vielleicht dann
auch wieder mehr weil ich weniger leide
die schalotten kommentar wie sehr ich
darf in diesem video fest einfach gut